تقفز تركل تتعلق بالحبال وتقاتل في حلبات
مشتركه مع الرجال ثم تحلق مع مخلوقات
خياليه وتعود الى الارض لتجسد شخصيات
حقيقيه تاره بجديه وتاره بسخريه الكوميديا
العصريه انها ميشيليو الفنانه العالميه
التي استحقت لقب ايقونه العام فما قصتها
ولدت ميشيليو في ايبو بماليزيا عام
وبدات مسيرتها المهنيه وهي في الرابعه من
عمرها كراقصه باليه قبل ان تفوز بلقب ملكه
جمال ماليزيا ولقب ملكه جمال مومبا في
استراليا في اوائل الثمانينيات ما ساعدها
على الظهور باعلان تلفزيوني مع النجم
الشهير جاكي تشان قبل ان تبدا مسيرتها
كممثله مقاتله بفيلم
وحينها كنيت باسم ميشيل خان في عام
1992 انفصلت ميشيل عن زوجها فعادت للتمثيل
مع فيلم بوليسي ستور 3 سوبر كابل ثم ظهرت
في افلام اخرى مثل
قبل ان تحصل على فرصتها الذهبيه وتنضم
لممثلي سلسله جيمس حيث ظهرت
عام
1997 ثم جاء اختيارها لدور قتالي عام 2000
بفيلم
وهو العمل الذي حازت عنه على جائزه افضل
ممثله مساعده في حفل توزيع جوائز جولدن
هورس لعام 2000 في عام 2002 بدات عملها
كمنتجه للافلام مع فيلم
وقامت ببطولته لكنه لم ينل الاستحسان
المطلوب لكنها لم تتوقف وتابعت الظهور
بافلام ناجحه فقدمت في الميدراما ميموريز
وفيلم ذا ليدي حيث جسدت السيره الذاتيه
لوزيره خارجيه ميانمارك
ثم عادت ومثلت شخصيه خياليه في فيلم
الخيال العالمي the مامي توم ضد دراغون
كما ظهرت بفيلم المغامره ودراما رين اوف
اساسنز الذي من اعلى الافلام ربحا انذاك
في السنوات الاخيره اختارت ميشيل اعمالها
بعنايه فلعبت دور البطوله في المسلسل
التلفزيوني الضخم ستار تريك ديسكفري ثم
ظهرت بدراما الكوميديه
وكلاهما حصل على ترشيحات عده لجوائز مهمه
ومع ذلك فان اكبر انجاز لها كان فيلم
الكوميديا
حيث قامت الفنانه البالغه من العمر 60
عاما باداء متميز لام مهاجره تحاول انقاذ
الكون فحصلت عنه على جائزه جولدن جلوب
لهذا العام وجوائز عديده اخرى وترشيحات
لجائزه الباف تا والاوسكار كما تم
اختيارها كايقونه العام من قبل مجله
التايمز
قدمت ميشيل خلال مسيرتها التي امتدت
لاربعه عقود من الزمن نحو 56 عملا وباتت
راقصه الباليه الماليزيه احد اهم اسماء
الصف الاول في هوليود واصبحت تتربع على
ثروه تقدر ب40 مليار دولار
[موسيقى]